tudo bom gente maravilha eu é muito
legal está fazendo
está podendo para estar aqui no ted uma
honra pra mim alguns meses atrás quando
recebi o convite fiquei muito feliz
fiquei muito honrado é porque sempre uma
realização nem sempre um som e eu eu
pensei em muita coisa elaborei um
roteiro é gente que trabalha com com a ç
a gente gosta é a cabeça bem sistemático
acaba sendo bem é detalhista bem
metodista e o preparei tudo o roteiro
todo aqui com questões técnicas falam
sobre comédia falando sobre a
importância da comédia no brasil as
diferenças entre a comédia brasileira ea
comédia americana que é onde a gente se
espelha onde stand up já está
estabelecido há 60 anos e tudo mais
e falando sobre a importante questão já
se acha com os assuntos que mais tratou
no meu novo show nos vídeos e e eu
percebi um aos 45 do segundo tempo que
estava a essa toda essa parece que eu
tinha uma todo o roteiro estava muito
mecânico estava muito robótico estava
muito bom estava muito sincero tava tão
honesto falam sobre questões técnicas
sobre toda essa questão que que envolve
a comédia aqui no brasil que é uma coisa
que facilmente você pode pesquisar em
livros e documentários tratando sobre
comédia e não tava real não tava sincero
tava pessoal eu acho que um dos motivos
de ter sido chamado para palestrar no
ted era justamente poder tratar sobre a
minha experiência minha curta
experiência é na comédia sobre essa
questão minha sobre como eu posso tratar
como posso levar isso sobre é é a
intolerância sobre o racismo sobre
qualquer outra coisa que entrasse no meu
show que falou sobre muitas coisas então
eu quero começar falando com vocês sobre
a a a comédia no brasil funciona a
primeira intenção nossa como comediante
é sempre o riso
sempre rezo o comediante ele se
distancia quando ele faz uma piada ele
se distancia daquela realidade por
alguns segundos e ele pega a piada seja
como for piada objeto dessa piada e e
trata daquilo tirando do contexto social
e colocando no contexto artístico e é é
toda essa introdução para vocês por dois
motivos um parecer inteligente
e o segundo motivo é que o último
primeiro motivo é só parece inteligente
mesmo coisa de vaidade minha brincadeira
segundo motivo que ele me faz entrar na
no assunto que eu vim tratar hoje aqui
que é a minha comédia que dizem utilizar
nenhum juízo de valor ela é diferente
não é melhor nem pior
ela tem essa a diferença porque eu gosto
de tratar eu quero falar a gente puder
durante muito tempo na minha
adolescência na minha quando eu descobri
esse amor pela comédia eu era pupo
motivos de de alívio sabe é todo mundo
pretos em geral e fim pessoas de
religiões de matriz africana tinham como
a vida inteira ser o alvo da piada
não que seja um problema mas a vida
inteira a gente nunca tinha escutado
outro lado a gente nunca tinha visto
outro lado a gente nunca tinha ido do
outro lado então isso provoca tem nem
existe essa provocação ea gente começou
a tratar disso agora é tudo muito novo
para a gente então voltando eu estava
falando eu comecei esse amor pela
comédia justamente pela provocação eu
era o cara que sempre fui o cara só até
hoje o cara que hoje as pessoas beberem
mil vídeos e brincam falam sobre eu ser
racista reversa tudo mais com os x mas
tentem existe isso eu sempre fui o cara
que chegava na praia sempre chegava na
praia é lá que seja com a família seja
com amigos presentes chegava na praia e
e um carrinho chinelo vamos pô eu falar
o chinelo com chinelo que está aí é que
tá acontecendo e eu sempre era o cara
que pegar essa provocação e ninguém
entende e apontar um preço caro a gente
ficar aqui o dia todo na praia é esse
cara a rosa
ninguém vai fazer piada com isso não
ninguém vai fazer pedra tá bom então eu
vou 8 bom você tá rosa é parece que você
teve a bater nos genes de tutti-frutti
vamos ajudar a esquisita
então é esse cara quer fazer essa
provocação e quando perceber que tinha
essa razão que estando agora essa risada
falei pô eu acho que consigo eu acho que
dá eo todo esse aprendizado nessa
tentativa e erro para tentar descobrir
se o outro lugar a comédia e porque é
por isso que eu acho que a gente chega
num ponto tão importante sabe chegou a
um ponto tão tão legal que é a
representatividade
é essa que é que é o mais bacana de você
ri porque a gente como público com
platéia gente ri você reúne esse
imediatismo da comédia é muito
fascinante ele porque você ri significa
que você entendeu logo você absorveu
aquilo é muito rápido mas fazer rir é
relativamente fácil fazer agora você
sorrir você chega a um show por exemplo
fazer um show como eu faço faço um com
um projeto que eu faço parte e você vê
90% da platéia preta entendeu nada conta
gente branca tem até a minha opção mas
você você vê uma platéia preta é muito
legal você sabe que a gente está
ocupando os espaços você sair do show e
ter uma pessoa ter uma uma mas ela é uma
menina universitária preta ativista de
25 anos que foi no seu show uma vez e
gostou e saiu do seu show não só com a
sensação de alegria que o show
proporcionou naquele contexto de teatro
naquele contexto de barro ou seja o que
for é uma sensação de caramba que legal
teve uma coisa nem aí
estou saindo com sorriso que eu tô
pensando sobre esse show ainda eu estou
conversando sobre esse assunto falando
com um amigo sobre esse show e essa
universitária leva o próximo show ela
leva a mãe dela sabe ela leva o pai dela
que nunca tem 60 anos e 65 anos e nunca
tinham ido ao teatro isso é muito
maravilhoso pessoas 65 anos o que sei lá
na década de 60 na década de 70 e 80
essa pessoa tinha 20 cruzeiros em
paralelo com a moeda da época e tinha
que no fim de semana decidindo poxa o
vou comprar pão e açúcar e arroz ou
então eu vou uma assistir no glauce
rocha é um cara fazendo uma borboleta pô
eu vou sobreviver então com a pessoa não
tinha e hoje em dia você ser o
responsável por essa pessoa de 60 anos
sair do teatro fala nossa primeira vez
que eu venho quero ver mais vezes é a
senhorinha que foi lá e assistir fala
nós preciso trazer minha vizinha aqui
você vai lá ela é branca melhor não sei
se ela vai mas é curioso isso é muito
perigoso e eu fico realmente realizada a
gente está ocupando os espaços
esse espaço que não eram na gente porque
a gente é volta nunca falei sobre
representatividade em pó
muita gente só então só vai gente se
identifica com aquilo que a gente sabe
que a mostra daquilo que a gente é é da
nossa realidade
então se você vai numa peça se você é
liga a televisão se você enfim tenho é
alguma um veículo de mídia que você não
se vê o seu não se espelha aquilo não
trata diretamente da sua realidade
ou trata da sua realidade de uma maneira
errada que era o que acontecia com as
piadas raciais antigamente a unegro
ladrão negro bandido negro isso negro de
cabelo ruim
haia o macumbeiro que que mata sei lá
mata cachorro que mata o macumbeiro que
faz isso o macumbeiro que chuta que é
macumba macumbeiro que é do demônio fala
carioca faz parte dessa religião isso
até engraçado que só não é verdade
entende então você não tem essa
identificação ea partir do momento que
você tem essa identificação quando subo
no palco e grito faz uma piada
enaltecendo o povo preto faz uma pedra
falando que mulher preto é deus eu faço
faço piada porque eu quero que as
pessoas olhem fala caramba de novo isso
e engraçado também porque é como eu
falei a primeira intenção ao riso assim
a gente pode além eu acho que é
importante que a gente vá aí então eu
quero trazer essa realidade porque se eu
chego no palco sul falando mulher preta
deus eu quero eu quero que ter um pouco
de sorriso com auto estima que a gente
não teve que foi roubada da gente como
várias as coisas foram roubadas da gente
então é como na minha adolescência eu
volto um pouco falando sobre ela falando
sobre eu chegar e está no grupo de
amigos ou vive em meios pouco elitista
sem mais demoras em favela eu
freqüentava as escolas particulares e
tudo mais a faculdade foi a mesma coisa
então quando eu tava eu tinha pelo menos
13 14 anos e lembro sempre achei
maravilhoso sempre achei divino méris
preta jovens pretas então eu olhar e
falar mas que aquela menina lhe nossa
menina bonita que minha preta bonita
isso na minha cabeça e meus amigos toda
menina passava e meus amigos acharam
aquela menina feia pra caramba né e até
mesmo matar nossa mesmo então isso é
muito porque eu não podia ter mais
aquilo porque era errado e aí você
cresce com essa consciência hoje em dia
se fala assim não cara eu vou falar isso
e aí você chega num show chega num vídeo
chega numa tv
aberta até falando que é macumbeiro a
pessoa pode chegar a um jovem que está
na escola que sofre muito com aquilo
falar não só a comer chegando trabalho
no dia seguinte
não preciso mais falar que é espírita
parecer mais fofinho sabe não precisa
falar que é católico aparecer mais
fofinho eu não sei em que contexto é que
as pessoas acham que católico parece
mais fofinho mas aparentemente falam
isso entendi então é a pessoa se sente
representado se sente feliz com aquilo
se sente é legal quando e até a a
apropuc é branco eu faço um show em
lugar de jonas sul é o centro de são
paulo que pública majoritariamente
branco e é muito é muito legal a gente é
muito legal você vê ele gino da piada e
no segundo seguinte elano e estou
falando de mim eu acho que era bem eu e
os meninos entendeu e está falando que
não tem boca mas eu superei boca eu
sempre tive boca entendi então é muito
legal isso é muito a pessoa saber ela
pessoa ri mesmo que é quando faz uma
piada um contexto racial por exemplo é
eu faço essa piada ea pessoa existiam os
dois tipos de pisada tem tem outros mas
os dois principais são a pessoa ri por
identificação ou a pessoa ri por
constrangimento que a gente sorri
daquilo que a gente sabe que existe
entre a gente concorda que existe então
existentes o tipo utilizado os dois pra
mim são maravilhosos porque mostra que
você é entender o que estou falando
mostre que você sabe que aquilo ali é
uma piada para ilustrar um determinado
comportamento chama de uma determinada
atitude e o que eu quero tratar aqui
hoje sobre essa reconstrução sobre a
redefinição eu quero dar uma nova
definição quero tentar quero aprender
talvez a dar uma nova definição para o
humor negro porque por muito tempo
mônego foi visto como o mo proibido o
humor pesado humor incorreto e eu quero
dar uma nova definição que pode ser o
humor do negro humor para o negro humor
que o negro sabe e até o humor com o
negro de vista de uma nova perspectiva
visto de um lugar que não era visto
ainda quando a gente faz esse tipo de
piada é essa reação nova é uma coisa
nova pra gente aqui nos estados unidos
comecei falando sobre isso é a comédia
já está muito bem estabelecida e lá há
segredo
são também está bem estabelecida então a
gente não tem essa falsa democracia
racial que a gente tem aqui no brasil
então os públicos sabem bem qual o lugar
com onde ele pode falar
os comediantes que estão nos holofotes
são os negros a nata da comédia stand up
dos estados unidos são os negros que
entende e aqui no brasil a gente não vi
não tinha um tinha de buscar essa
representatividade na comédia stand up
que ainda adolescente aqui no rio e no
rio no brasil não temos 15 anos só de
comédia stand up ea gente não via os
negros nos holofotes não viu os negros
tratando dessa questão racial como é que
é isso no contexto do brasil como é que
funciona isso então a gente começa a
tratar desse assunto e é novo então caso
um dos dois tipos de ações tanto a
reação tudo que é novo é o sesi causa
reação né
a razão de nossa isso é muito legal cara
a gente nunca tinha visto isso eu gosto
disso e razão de rejeição tipo não está
errado que é até um pouco camuflada com
racismo racismo velado que a gente tem
que o tenho tempo mas a gente tem aqui
no no brasil se rasgum vê-la
desfazimento institucional
então quando eu quero quando eu trago
essa nova definição de modelo é
justamente pra isso justamente pra gente
se ambientar para a gente trazer pra
gente pensar sobre o modo negro pensar
sobre a realização porque que a minha
platéia hoje em dia é composta de 90 80%
de negros porque eu não subir no palco e
faço piadas sobre ônibus eu faço piada
sobre o que eles passam dentro dos
ônibus
sobre toda a realidade racial seja é s10
seja a moda é sobretudo ahmed darrat céu
mostra que a gente passa mesmo e isso
causa identificação que é o cara e é eu
gosto disso gosto de ficar falando sobre
cabelo e falando que nosso cabelo na
verdade é maravilhoso nosso cabelo é bom
que nosso cabelo na ruim eu eu acho
interessante esse movimento novo que a
gente faz aqui no brasil que a gente
traz nesse é essa realidade de comédia
nesse mediatismo da comédia vai além da
risada da risada pela risada
foi um pouco de é eu acho interessantes
e falou tem um conteúdo histórico tem um
conteúdo político tem uma coisa ea gente
vai aprendendo muito e eu quero poder
devolver ao público quero poder devolver
a platéia
o time da que é a satisfação que a
alegria da platéia me devo me me joga
isso com o amor que eu tenho pelo pelo
que eu faço
pela roupa fui falar de macumba teve um
negócio aqui até senti isso quando
entrei mas teve quem não quis falar pra
assustar vocês mas quando eu trata sobre
essas questões eu quero devolver bota eu
quero empurrar pra platéia com todo o
carinho do mundo com todo a piada com
toda alegria com todo o humor com toda
comédia isso que protege a mída sabe que
é você sair do palco ea platéia trazia a
pessoa seja ela quem for a pessoa jovem
a pessoa às velha a pessoa enfim é preta
branca trazer essa alegria que ela
quando ela vem de cumprimentar convém
trazer ela traz o melhor dela ela vem
com a ligação nossa como gostei disso
obrigado pelo seu trabalho
obrigado por essa mensagem obrigado
pelas risadas brigado por deixar meu dia
minha semana enfim é mais leve porque é
honesto quando subo no palco e falo
maioria das coisas que eu falo é muito
mais quando estou aqui no tahiti falando
sobre a importância do humor negro sobre
a redefinição do do morro negro sobre
toda a questão racial no brasil sobre a
questão de intolerância sobre a questão
de dias de não fazer apenas grata pela
piada e às vezes fazer também porque a
gente gosta muito de se divertir
é como diz o povo brasileiro é um povo
feliz é um povo alegre
não sei por que mas a gente é que
continue sempre sendo mas é importante
isso eu quero poder devolver isso quero
poder trazer isso pra gente eu quero
poder entender mas eu quero poder
aprender mais sobre sobre a comédia no
brasil sobre todas as questões brasil
fazer piada sobre todo tipo de coisa a
fazer piada sobre meu filho fazer piada
sobre a família fazer piada sobre
política fazer piada sobre um corrimão
da escada seja o que for que entende mas
que a aaa em todas essas têm o conteúdo
da risada que têm um conteúdo de você
sorrir
além de hits você sorrir além de
gargalhar que você transmite allen tudo
tudo muito além
sabe como eu disse para vocês eu eu
muito feliz aqui eu quero que o
todos riam todos se divirtam eu quero
que o negro rio negro gargalhe sabe a
gente tem é esse lugar por direito que o
negro ia que eu sorria que lugar dá lhe
que o negro shore mas que seja de ri e
principalmente como falei no início
desse mês idade
eu quero que o negro ria quero ver o
shore mas a minha primeira intenção é o
riso
meu nome é yuri maçã foi uma honra me
apresentar a vocês muito obrigado por
lei